pat talked to us about Jordan the power
of this 21 year old and his
marketability well now that he's one of
master staff certainly puts him on a new
light joining the likes of Rory McIlroy
and Tiger Woods being obviously Rory
wanted a early age Tiger certainly won
an early age speak last year Steph made
about six million dollars in
endorsements you compare him to another
young dong Rory McIlroy who's won four
major championships he's 25 years old
and Rory makes about 30 million annually
in endorsements Jordan won't get there
just yet but he may not be far away if
he keeps winning could this do a lot for
golf in general between Rory and Jordan
both being young exciting golfers to
watch could this be sort of an exciting
new story that we're gonna watch over
the next 10 to 20 years the rivalry
between these two certainly as a golf
fan myself I hope it does I have worried
about what's going to happen to the
sport when Tiger and Phil Mickelson for
example finally lose their competitive
edge and and they're arguably they've
already seen a decline in their
respective careers so I think Golf is
hoping that these two guys Oh as well as
Bubba Watson Rickie Fowler hopefully
these guys can carry the mantle going
forward but you know you can't deny
Tigers affect Steph the ratings this
weekend 50% up on Saturday 23% up
yesterday Tiger and Rory were in the mix
but maybe people were watching for Tiger
and fell in love with Jordan hopefully
so you know and of course the other
interesting thing I wrote about this
yesterday in Forbes Steph is you know
how ironic that a guy named Jordan could
be the thorn in the side for Nike
because he is represented by Under
Armour and I think that's where he could
really see a boost he's only in his
third year of a five-year deal with
Under Armour but Under Armour is going
to be desperate to want to retain his
services because that's that is their
face of golf and the underarm division
Pat house golf's marketability different
today from when Tiger first won the
Masters back in 97
well with Tiger Eric it was such a
different feel you know he was a
youngster coming onto the scene there
hadn't been a young gun of that epic
stature since Jack Nicklaus in the 60s
throw on top of that the social
significance of Tiger Woods being really
the first dominant minority athlete in
that sport
jordan Spieth can't accomplish those
sorts of things he's not gonna have the
same cultural social effect but that
doesn't mean that he can't have a real
impact and even though rory mcilroy is
great Eric because he's not an American
he's only going to be able to have so
much cachet as an endorser in the States
how much of a loss is this for Nike we
saw Under Armour's stock already up this
morning and you know Jordans the face of
the company in terms of golf
I think Nikes gonna be fine I think
they'll survive
Justin Spieth winning a few majors
because again they've got Rory McIlroy
they still have Tiger Woods I certainly
anticipate Tiger will be competitive
he's just just shy of 40 I think he
still has another five good years in him
Rory McIlroy he's got another 15 20
years so Nike will be fine what do you
think about golf's popularity let's say
Pat there's a jordan Spieth combined
with Rory McIlroy revive the game of
golf at least for an American audience
because as we know for a young audience
fewer and fewer people are playing golf
at least I mean if I'm not mistaken
hundreds of thousands fewer people than
played just a few years ago Eric you hit
the nail on the head in fact that the
world Sports Congress recently out here
in Los Angeles people from all the
different sports talked about how
valuable getting young people to watch
their sport play their sport so crucial
for fan of inity later in life and golf
despite jordan Spieth success and and
hopefully him and Rory kind of carrying
the mantle you have seen a decline in
the play of golf for a variety of
reasons the recession people are simply
busier there's more distractions so I
think this will minimize the letdown in
the sport but unfortunately I think golf
is in that decline state I don't know
what
they're gonna be able to rebound what
are their brands what labels could want
to go after Jordan right now he is sort
of this new exciting face and the fact
that he's 21 kind of taps into a
different demographic certainly you know
of course apart from Under Armor he's
got deals with AT&T Titleist Rolex I
think any brand that's more of an
upscale trying to cater to the younger
demographic would be the ones that would
go after him are you potentially an
energy drink it could be in his future
but he's already you know aligned with
some brands within his sport in
particular that kind of cater to the
younger crowd so that's who I would be
looking at is companies that kind of
cater to a younger demographic were you
rooting for impact you know it's funny I
want to I'm Phil Mickelson guy so I did
want to see it be a little bit more
competitive yesterday but you know again
it was history and I think one of the
cool things about being a fan of the
sport of golf is there's a lot of
different guys to root for Rudy for
Tiger to eventually kind of reach you
know get back to close to where he was
Justin Rose the Englishman he's a nice
story as well so the great thing about
being a golf fan you can tell I'm
passionate about the sport is there's
nice storylines for everybody but
certainly watching Jordan speith make
history yesterday that was something
special